here's another thing people don't know
about you i think that you're one of the
best riffers out there and i want to
learn how to riff you want to learn how
to rip yeah because i've never learned
how to riff right out so let's play it
out how do you riff so
let's say i'm in the audience okay right
you're on stage right and i go
you suck
uh-huh what would you say i'd go
get this guy the [ __ ] out of here
oh
no that's not true take him out of the
room yeah um no you you just if someone
is aggressive like that then you just
you go twice as aggressive right at him
cause you're so good at that you're so
mean in in a good way
yeah you gotta
you know
i look at performing comedy like it's
joining the military and that's you
sacrifice one
for the good of many
so if you have to attack one or you find
two or three enemies in the crowd and
then you make it about how the rest of
us are against them and that way people
don't take their side ever yeah
and you can't you can't attack women
unless
the woman starts shouting or acting
intoxicated and then everyone in the
world hates them and then wow extra hard
at them right but you can't go after
somebody that doesn't say anything
i mean you can it just depends if people
think you're truly being a bully
you'll lose some of the crowd but if
they think you're
being mean to someone who's probably a
piece of [ __ ] then they go i'm i'm glad
someone's finally saying it yeah because
what i've done on stage is i'll see
somebody in the front row
and i did this last week which is not
good
and i go there's this guy with you know
his big face in the front row and i go
look at your fat cheeks and i poked his
cheek yeah right and as i
took my finger away you could feel the
skin go back you know i mean
yeah yeah right so i made a little thing
went
like that and i backed up and looked at
his face and he went he was like
oh yeah and he hit the sad face and he
goes
and i kind of looked away yeah
that's the so that's the key that's not
good once once you do something that's
mean or the crowd isn't into you just
got to move on as quickly as possible i
know but my point is that you when
you're an audience member you should
understand that like anything goes right
that's their fault if i poke your ch i
mean and then then if anything goes then
okay let's suppose i'm in the crowd
you're doing a set right yeah
like you're a fat [ __ ] bobby yeah what
would you say that do i know you or no
no it's kalila my
delilah
yeah don't do that
don't ever do that that would make me so
mad if you did that
really yeah here's my girlfriend again i
don't know i think if it was a normal
person i would just be like i think i
would just agree yeah okay
i know i know i am thank you thank you
as always yeah thank you someone says
something really insulting yeah just
take it with pride i think because i
know i'm a piece of [ __ ]
do you feel like a piece of [ __ ] yeah
yeah i think deep down in the states on
when i'm on stage deep down inside i
mean i feel like i'm a piece of [ __ ]
right and so i attack people
you know i mean as a defense mechanism
to keep people away right but when
somebody actually does say something
personal on stage like a comic can
really get me
i mean there's a two or three things
that a comic can say
to me
that will ruin